when a technology becomes personal
when a technology becomes desktop it
doesn't just get cheaper smaller better
more ubiquitous what happens is it gets
used in different ways so what's really
exciting to me about the era the the
moment here of desktop manufacturing is
not just the tools it's what people will
do with them and what i can't wait to
see
is when you put 3d printers in every
school the kids are going to do things
we can't imagine the they're good at
this stuff right they understand
geometries and designing on screen they
play video games it's the same thing
polygons are their native language they
have ideas we can only imagine and now
they're empowered to not only put them
on the screen but then print them out
and if they're cool print them out in
more numbers manufacture become
entrepreneurs and compete with the
existing industrial structure of
manufacturing to do something entirely
new right now our 3d printers are one
color and they're relatively slow and
the relatively low resolution they're
dot matrix printers if you will but you
know you don't have to cast your mind
forward that far before you start to
bring in other materials maybe you can
add electronics into this and so you can
integrate electronics into an object and
now you're starting to get that kind of
star trek fantasy where you basically
ask for something you know
tea earl grey whatever it finds the
files the necessary you know
instructions to the computer online
somewhere it mixes together some raw
materials to create you know the right
compounds it produces it quickly at the
right resolution and you have something
that in the past would have been mass
manufactured and and one size fits all
and now it's just in time manufactured
perfect for you we've had cnc machines
and laser cutters and other other sort
of industrial tools but they weren't
desktop and they weren't personal and
they weren't easy to use and they
weren't cheap
and that's the change if it's easy to
use
then it gets out of the way
and then it becomes a vector for ideas
to turn to things turn into companies
and turn into movements
and
that moment that macintosh moment is
right now
you